in season 2 of Chucky there's a scene
where the kids gather materials to help
them reprogram Chucky's brain and if you
look closely one of these materials is a
tape that once belonged to Eddie Caputo
a boy who attended this very same
boarding house years ago and later went
on to become Chucky's getaway driver as
seen in the original movie not only is
this a fun Easter egg but it also
establishes the idea that Charles and
Eddie may have items tucked away in
hidden places throughout the school an
idea that comes back in a huge way at
the end of this season to learn about
all of the Easter eggs references hidden
secrets glaring mistakes and everything
you might have missed stick around to
the end of this video this video is
sponsored by hellofresh
humans
okay if you watch my videos you may
remember how I was relieved when I was
finally done covering bride and sea I
only did it so that my Chucky series
could be considered complete and we
could move on to the serious stuff then
in season one the main focus was how
that season was a tribute to Child's
Play 2 which Creator Don Mancini
explained was because so many fans
consider Child Play 2 to be their
favorite My Hope Was That season 2 would
take the next logical step and honor
Child's Play 3. after all like Child's
Play 3 it was going to take place at a
boarding school and it would feature a
small militia of Chucky dolls opposing
Andy the inverse of Child's Play 3 which
features a small militia of kids
opposing Chucky however as I watched
season 2 I came to a horrifying
realization this wasn't in homage to the
third movie it was an homage to the
fifth one Seed of Chucky
as a result Chucky season 2 throws
horror out the window pun intended and
it's all about comedy gross out moments
celebrity cameos meta horror references
and way too much Petty bickering I've
gotta commend Mancini for having the
balls to do this I'm sure he knows how
fans feel about seed yet he's stuck to
his guns and gave us more of it four
times more regardless of my feelings
towards the season I still feel like it
contains some interesting things you may
have missed so let's get into it
[Music]
the season picks up right where the
previous one left off with Andy
hijacking the truck full of Chuck in
order to try and Destroy them it's here
that we meet the doll that would later
become known as the colonel he gets into
it with two others and I have a fan
theory about who one of them is listen
to this line yeah well they also say it
ain't the size it counts so I wouldn't
worry about those pathetic dick arms of
yours my theory is that this insult
inspired this Chucky to take steroids
resulting in the creation of one of The
Season's antagonists in buff Chucky as
soon as I saw Andy drive the truck over
the ledge I was screaming he didn't get
out of the Kaka duty truck coming to
find out he actually didn't for some
reason he just somehow miraculously
survived the crash which happens right
at the foot of this giant Cross perhaps
a foreshadowing of the religious setting
for this season season 2 episode 1 is
titled Halloween 2 because it's the
second Chucky episode that takes place
on Halloween however there is a double
meaning here because there are going to
be similarities to the 1981 movie
Halloween 2. the jack-lanterns in the
intro have Chucky's face carved into
that in the same style as the skull on
the poster for Halloween too during the
episode we see that Jake carved one of
the Chucky lanterns himself I don't know
why he would traumatize himself like
that but he does as I mentioned in my
video on season one Dr Mixter is named
after a character from Halloween 2. so
these references may be our clue that Dr
Mixter is going to play a bigger role
this season a role that would make her
align more with a different doctor from
the Halloween franchise Dr Sartain the
psychiatrist of a serial killer who
becomes so invested in his patient that
he becomes evil himself but from Bride
of Chucky onwards I'm pretty sure that
all of my Chucky analyzes have made
mention of the horror movie franchise
that Chucky takes on the most the scream
franchise this season it may be the most
blatant scream emulation of all it
starts with Jake receiving a phone call
from Chucky and doing his best ghost
face impression
hello is Tamara home who Tamara this is
actually kind of a hybrid Easter egg the
phone call and voice resembled the
beginning of scream but the lion is
actually lined from the beginning of the
strangers when one of the titular
strangers shows up at the door is Tamara
here no
now you got the wrong house the rest of
the phone call plays out like a typical
scream opening with Chucky asking him
questions such as why he's home alone
revealing familiarity with Jake by
asking about a significant other then
frightening Jake by proving that real
danger is afoot the doorbell rings but
nobody is out front and Jake grabs a
knife it's all just like screen at first
he thinks it's a classmate named Ellis
which may be a reference to Major Ellis
the bully character from Child's Play 3.
we've seen this move before this isn't
Ellis I'm not Randy the screaminess
continues later in this episode when
Devon recognizes Caroline's new doll
from something she looks a little like
the Bride of Chucky
remember that movie yeah with Jennifer
Tilly we do know that there are movies
about Chucky already because part of
seed took place on the set of a movie
called Chucky goes psycho however this
is the first time we're hearing that the
actual Chucky movies in our world may
also exist in their world which is the
concept originated in the scream
franchise which contains the in-universe
stab franchise in addition to Chucky yo
psycho and Bride of Chucky it seems Seed
of Chucky also exists in some form in
the Chucky Universe because you can spot
a poster for it in Jennifer Tilly's
House the show continues to lean heavily
on Scream throughout the season Nika
borrows a line from Casey Becker
[Music]
listen and the rest of these will
contain spoilers for scream so just skip
to the next chapter if you haven't seen
them in episode 3 we learned that there
are two Chuckies operating at the school
just as there are always two Ghost Face
killers in every Scream movie in episode
8 Glenda kills someone with a
defibrillator hey Mom
clear
it's like in scream four
have one final word what please
clear
clear notes that one might actually be
more of a reference to the first Child's
Play where Chucky kills Dr Ardmore with
some kind of shock device at the
hospital but like Scream the Chucky
franchise goes to New York City in 2023
which is possibly a really big
coincidence however the aspect of scream
that is most borrowed from Chucky is the
fact that the characters are self-aware
and know about horror movies the season
is littered with parodies and homages so
I'm going to talk about most of them and
uncover even more things you missed
[Music]
I had been using hellofresh on my own
for about a year before they ever
reached out to sponsor a video each meal
comes with a recipe page so at the
beginning I decided to save some of the
recipes that I really liked this is it
as you can tell it's basically every
single recipe hellofresh is the
essential meal kit delivery service
everything you need to cook delicious
Chef crafted recipes is delivered to
your doorstep so you can spend more time
doing the things you love you'll only
find quality ingredients and help
Fresh's recipes in fact ingredients
travel from the farm to your home in
less than seven days so you know that
they're fresh I love how you get the
perfect amount of ingredients to make
your meal no more going to the grocery
store to get cilantro for a recipe but
then they only sell way more than you
need and 75 of it goes bad in the fridge
later that week no more each week you
can choose what you want from over 40
weekly dishes but you don't have to if
I'm too busy I'll let it choose for me
and honestly I've discovered some of my
favorites that way it's healthy it uses
sustainable recycle friendly materials
and it saves money so it really checks
all the boxes for me I've been telling
everybody in my life about hellofresh
for the past year and they always ask me
if I'm sponsored and I say no it's just
been a life changer for me I guess I
won't be able to say that anymore but
with this amazing deal you can just go
to hellofresh.com and use code cz's
world six five for 65 off plus free
shipping that's go to cz's world 6'5 at
hellofresh.com to get 65 off then brag
about it to all of your friends
foreign
episode we see an angel and a devil
trick-or-treating together which I see
as a foreshadowing of the good and evil
metaphor that comes up so often during
the season we already know about Nika
and Chucky a good character and an evil
character being forced to share one body
something similar appears to happen
after Jake and Devin capture a Chucky
Scout and attempt to reprogram his brain
Chucky pretends that he's torn between
good Chucky and bad Chucky due to the
religious setting Chucky is constantly
portrayed as the devil and they even
perform an exorcism on him at the end
when Jake and Devin first show up at
Lexi's house she's listening to the song
The Devil I know by Ali ax and this also
foreshadows The Exorcism of Chucky
contrary to that newcomer Nadine is the
Angel Chucky takes her out by stating
that fairies love to fly before throwing
her out a window but she comes back to
speak to Lexi in the form of an Angel
which is actually just a suit with
lights but I'm not here to talk about
the costume budgets in addition to the
contrast shown between good and evil the
show also explores the gray area between
the two with many good characters
expressing feelings of guilt we get to
see how each of them deals with guilt
differently the first is actually Lexi's
mom Mrs cross
for everyone who lost somebody in last
year's tragic events I know exactly what
they're going through because I'm going
through it too the grief
the anger
the guilt
the survivors guilt it's not known how
much she really struggles with guilt
considering most of what she does is
fake for social media but we see
survivors guilt manifest much more
convincingly in jail during an art
history class about the seven deadly
sins he asked his teacher if there are
some sins that are unforgivable still
shaken by the fact that his innocent
Foster brother lost his life due to
Jake's connection with Chucky in a later
class that teacher senses the guilt
eating at him you think I'm overcome
with guilt
I think something's eating away at you
and sure enough Jake's guilt ties back
into the main plot it's the reason that
he wants to keep Scout Chucky alive
I try and do it a different way all I
feel is guilt
if I really want to forgive myself
I have to be able to forgive him first
Nadine has a different relationship with
Guild she feels guilt over her bad habit
with stealing things but unlike Jake
she's a little too comfortable with
letting go events as long as she
declares her sins in the confessional it
all goes away so she often ends up with
long sessions in the booth completely
missing the point of why she's there
however this makes her a perfect
companion to Lexi who keeps all of her
guilt bottled up inside through her
final conversation with Angel Nadine
she's finally able to share her feelings
with those she loves Devin on the other
hand tries to deal with his guilt by
physically overcoming it seeing it as a
sickness I thought you were sick you
shouldn't be out of bed if that's the
case oh maybe it's just something hey or
maybe the feeling isn't biological maybe
it's more philosophical guilt it has a
funny way of manifesting in us the point
is that each character has their own way
of handling guilt the protagonists find
a way to handle it while the antagonists
make no attempt to address it which all
comes to a head before the exorcism
where each of them must make their
confessions in order to proceed it's
probably the most well-written through
line in the season I wish I could say
the same about how Dr mixter's character
was set up I mean our family therapist
can't be in League with a supernaturally
possessed doll right
by the way in Lexi's room there's a blue
oyster Cults poster a reference to her
singing the song and Don't Fear the
Reaper to Caroline is a lullaby in
season one another season one connection
can be seen in this guy James he's
interviewing Mrs cross and he's actually
the same guy that interviewed her when
she was the mayor throughout season one
crazy how no one in the media is putting
together that the Chucky dolls attached
to so many of these tragedies after a
family therapy sesh Dr mixer gives
Caroline the new doll to help her cope
with her fear of dolls this is kind of a
call back to the seventh movie Cult of
Chucky where Tiffany claims that this
Good Guy doll was used to help Alice
Pierce overcome her family's Chucky
related tragedy anyway when it comes to
Caroline's doll Lexi smashes it against
the ground to try to make sure that it
isn't alive and we see the same camera
angle used when Junior used Chucky as a
blunt object to attack his dad with last
season this could be a tiny clue that
this wedding bell doll is actually
Chucky in Disguise Lexi's precautions
don't save her from being targeted by
Chucky who brings a homemade bomb and
detonates it on Jake's younger Foster
Brother Gary knowing the truth won't be
believed they make up a story about how
they built a homemade
um which was accidentally detonated this
is what landslim in the Catholic school
I get why they don't want Chucky being
alive to be part of their story but
their cover story that they made the
bomb themselves doesn't make them look
any better this is so stupid they find
themselves being transported to the
Catholic School in a blue School Bus
kind of reminiscent of Andy being
shipped to the military school in
Child's Play 3. season 2 episode 2 the
Sinners are much more fun is titled
after a lyric from the Billy Joel song
Only the Good Die Young and opens with
some franchise Easter eggs in a Jennifer
Tiffany's house there's a never before
seen photo from Glenn and Glenda's 5th
birthday party in Seed of Chucky which
sits alongside Jennifer's most improved
actress award also from C in that film
it was used by Tiffany to knock out
Redman and in this season Glenda uses it
to knock out Glen moving on through the
house Tiffany has a huge mirror above
her bed and when she wakes up screaming
it begins to crack it wouldn't be the
first time that she cracked a ceiling
mirror because in Bride of Chucky two of
her kills come as the result of a
champagne bottle hurled at the mirror
above a bed at a motel back at the
school Jake Devon and Lexi are sitting
in on their first time only with the
Headmaster father Bryce who loves using
metaphors on God's Team every confession
is a victory and God sure does love a
winner does
she probably dislikes Sports metaphors
because of the Super Bowl of Slaughter
speech that Chucky gave Jake in season
one that almost convinced him to take
Lexi out here's an instant replay
it's the Super Bowl of Slaughter
and you can't just sit in the stands you
know
we all gotta get out there and get in
the game unfortunately for Lexi there
would be an all-out Blitz of sports
metaphors in season two sure you boys
are anxious to get on straight and
narrow get your lives back on track back
on the right track
back on the fast track I just love
sports metaphors episode 3 would be
titled Hail Mary which in addition to
the religious practice is also a play in
football which is usually used as a
last-ditch effort at the end of a game
not that I would know as a Bears fan it
makes sense though because brainwashing
Chucky is Jake's last-ditch attempts to
give himself closure about what happened
to Gary unfortunately he's
underestimated his opponent unlike the
MVP of Serial murder he even manages to
pull off the upsets in episode 5 against
buff chugging how did I do coach and
later on in preparation to go up against
the colonel Jake Works another Sports
metaphor into his game plan you know
whatever battle this Colonel has Brewing
we need to have it on our own terms what
terms would those be home core Advantage
all those Sports metaphors have gotten
me gas so I'm gonna take a short time
out but when I come back I'm gonna be
dealing even more things you missed
foreign
of Chucky there is another evil lurking
in the halls of Incarnate Lord Lexi's
childhood bully Trevor in season one
Lexi was the bully so she tries to
channel some of that energy to push back
against Trevor effectively creating a
bully vs bully scenario when I first saw
this I wondered if it could be
foreshadowing of an eventual Chucky vs
Chucky battle of some kind and it later
came to fruition but in order to get
there the second Chucky had to be snuck
into the school so a good guy doll is
mailed as a part of sister Ruth's
Christmas toy drive even though it's
still weeks away it's wonderful sister
Elizabeth a time like the present is
that supposed to be a pun because
presents like Christmas presents the
students aren't supposed to have access
to phones so the trio has theirs
confiscated and noted on this document
to keep track of which phone belongs to
whom let's zoom in on the names one of
them is Moro La Caprara this is the name
of a production designer who has worked
on many major TV shows filmed in Toronto
such as the handmaid's tale and Clarisse
Chucky was also filmed in Toronto it
doesn't appear that he worked on it but
many of his jobs went on credited so
that could be the case again I'm gonna
count it as a crew reference Easter egg
and speaking of it being filmed in
Toronto Lexi has two posters in her room
for the small toronto-based rock band
Kingdom of birds as sister Elizabeth is
tagging each of the guests there are a
few more crew references this red tag is
labeled at the Mancini family after
Chucky series Creator Don Mancini the
white tag says the colavecchia family
named after Daniel and John colavecchia
who worked in the camera Department the
green tag says the mercobita family
James and Steve mercobita also worked
camera departments there's also a tough
to spot Easter egg in episode 1. when
Lexi is rummaging through her mother's
medicine cabinet one of the bottles was
prescribed by Dr Douglas Gaber which is
a slightly altered version of Gabriella
Douglas the first assistant art director
there's not another crew reference
Easter egg until episode 7 when Bryce
brings out the exorcism for dummy's book
which is the play on the voodoo for
dummies book introduced in Bride
exorcism for dummies is written by
Richard darling a reference to Rick
darling the property Master on both
seasons one and two it turns out that
Tiffany held on to Voodoo for dummies we
see it again in episode 8. it's written
by Don Mancini and that's our last crew
reference Easter egg while not
technically a crew reference there is a
meta horror moment when Jay comments
that father Bryce reminds him of his dad
that's because Mr Wheeler his brother
Logan and father Bryce are all played by
the same actor Devin Sawa the first
victim of the Season other than Tiffany
and all those Chuckies and Gary his
sister Elizabeth who has a heart attack
just upon seeing him
just looking at me is scary enough to
give you a heart attack he shouldn't be
that surprised because this has happened
before it's a reference to the way that
Colonel Cochran was killed in Child's
Play 3 and it's another reason that I
thought season 2 was going to be a
tribute to that third movie but as you
know it went in the direction of Seed of
Chucky carrying on its tradition of
bombarding us with needless pop culture
references I'm gonna go through them but
if you're not interested in that feel
free to skip to the next chapter when
Chucky holds them hostage at the
beginning he mocks their friendship for
not spending more time together and this
is Devin's rebuttal we've been busy well
now you're all Gonna Get Busy Dying that
might be a reference to the Shawshank
Redemption
it comes down to a simple Choice really
get busy living
don't get busy die I'm sure you didn't
miss the Scooby-Doo reference and I
would have gotten away with it too if it
weren't for you meddling kids after the
truck crashed the head of the female
doll somehow ends up in Tiffany's bed
a parody of the horse had scene from The
Godfather
later that day Tiffany can be seen
watching liar liar and when Nika makes
this comment I know you went through all
fertility Simpsons money Jennifer Tilly
isn't on The Simpsons so what's the deal
with this luckily I happen to know a
Simpsons expert who can explain it much
better than I can here's the Simpsons
Theory hey guys no I want to start off
by saying that although Jennifer Tilly
wasn't a regular cast member in The
Simpsons she was previously married to
late Simpsons co-creator Sam Simon and
when it came to their divorce in 1993 a
percentage of Simon's payments from Fox
was awarded to her then she later
appeared as herself in season 24's gone
a be gone where she even references said
Simpson's money I've read every expert
on poker and watched Jennifer Tilly's
DVD start with your Simpsons money use a
little girl voice and take him for
everything they've got
now I'm kneaded on the set of Bride of
Chucky 5. and there you have it folks
that is your random Simpsons fact of the
day thanks so much for having me on Zack
thank you Lydia I'll put a link to her
channel in the description moving along
when the kids try to reprogram Chucky
they clip his eyes open using what
appears to be hair clips as a parody of
the brainwashing scene in A Clockwork
Orange where Alex is conditioned to feel
nausea whenever he's exposed to violence
which is exactly what happens to Chucky
instead of showing him war footage they
show him horror movies like the thing
and psycho 2. in episode 4 the twins
invite some guests over to celebrate
their birthday behind Tiffany's bag well
we figured you wouldn't want to have
people over given your Norma Desmond
Vibes as a flame Norma Desmond is be
forgotten silent movie star in the 1950
Noir film Sunset Boulevard who similar
to Tiffany never leaves her mansion and
Revels in the past watching her own
movies in Tiffany's case they aren't
actually her movies but you get the
point both characters are delusional and
insane not long after Tiffany apologizes
to her guests for being a recluse over
the last year and says that she's
entering her Garbo ERA this is a
reference to another silent film Stone
Greta Garbo who is known for her
melancholic role so essentially nothing
like Tiffany or Jennifer Tilly which
makes it kind of funny if you know who
Greta Garbo is later on when buff Chucky
is discovered by Sister Ruth who
mistakes him for a God he makes more of
a 90s reference
I like your style Sister Act
Sister Act is a comedy franchise
starring Whoopi Goldberg never mind the
fact that Chucky was dead in 1992 when
the first one came out dead in 1993 when
the second one came out and it was
literally just a dismembered arm in 2006
when the Broadway musical Premiere the
creators of the show clearly care a lot
more about referencing their favorite
IPS than having their own show make any
logical sense it gets a really bad
shortly after when I first saw the bald
Chucky known as the colonel I thought it
had something to do with the end of
Child's Play too or the beginning of
Child's Play 3 where we see the factory
that the good guys are made in and some
of them have now received hair yet it
wasn't until this very strange scene
that I ended up looking into the
character and discovered who he's really
supposed to be and I have a lot to say
about it
foreign
to an iconic character from the 1979 war
movie known as Apocalypse Now his name
is Colonel Walter Kurtz and he's a rogue
army officer who went insane and started
commanding his own troops in Cambodia
kind of like how the colonel on Chucky
sets up his own camp in the wilderness
and commands his own unit of good guy
dolls after Andy gets the better of him
in episode 6 the colonel repeatedly says
the horror before passing away a clear
takeoff of Colonel Kurtz's final moments
in Apocalypse Now We're shown flashbacks
of the Vietnam War Charles Lee Ray was
never in the Vietnam War it began before
he was born and ended when he was 16. in
my opinion the mere Act of referencing
another property doesn't make it funny
if you're doing it in a way that adds
entertainment value then that's one
thing but just putting a random War
flashback that doesn't even fit just
because Francis Ford Coppola did it
isn't all that entertaining let's look
at the Simpsons again as an example The
Simpsons love a good Parody episode
every year they do Treehouse of Horror
but part of the fun of watching
Treehouse of Horror is learning how the
establish characters of Springfield will
change a horror story that we already
know in The Treehouse of Horror 3
segment clown Without Pity Homer buys
his son a talking crusty doll for his
birthday it's a parody of Child's Play
but they don't just run through the plot
of the movie they use the talking murder
doll Concept in a way that fits the
style and humor that we love in The
Simpsons take this object but beware it
carries a terrible curse oh that's bad
but it comes with a free throw gut
that's good the frogat is also cursed
that's bad but you get your choice of
topping that's good the toppings contain
potassium benzoate
that's bad can I go now you don't have
to have seen Child's Play to appreciate
clown Without Pity but if you haven't
seen Apocalypse Now good luck
understanding what the hell that Colonel
Kurtz reference was also this scene is a
total disaster roll it
or give me death remember
the Alamo
who's gone what is going on here why is
Lexi asking who's Khan it almost feels
like she's responding to a line that was
cut from the show has the editing really
gotten that bad here's my last thing on
this topic when your media references
are just references for the sake of
references you start to lose Clarity of
if they even are references for example
take Tiffany's line towards Caroline
like was that supposed to be a Jurassic
Park reference
was she just calling Caroline clever you
can't even tell anymore anyways rant
over let's get back to where we were
episode two I mentioned that Tiffany was
watching Jennifer Tilly's performance in
liar liar and in that same episode
father Bryce makes Jake read a Biblical
passage about lies when he lies he
speaks according to his own nature
for he is a liar
the father of Lies it's very fitting
that lies are such a big focus on this
episode because Chucky's lives would
have a Major Impact when he acts as if
he's been changed by the Clockwork
Orange treatments the characters drop
their guard around him allowing him to
make one of the most devastating kills
of the series moving on to episode 3 we
meet father O'Malley who is clearly
tired of Nadine coming in every week to
do a confession with him the character
is a tribute to Reverend William
O'Malley who is known for his portrayal
of father Dyer in The Exorcist where he
also serves as a technical advisor of
all the films that Chucky season 2
imitates the strongest influence other
than scream is probably the Exorcist but
I'll come back to that later in this
video when I talk about the ending
during stage one of the brainwashing
scene one of the disturbing clips that
they show Chucky is someone falling out
of a window onto a car it's the exact
same as the first kill we ever saw
Chucky make and Maggie in the original
movie
then and during stage two he sees Nadine
setting up the phone and says this
Chuck he wants to watch the nine o'clock
news
this is the exact line said by Andy
shortly after meeting Chucky in the
original in his days State this was
probably triggered by seeing Nadine who
looks similar to and has the same
hairstyle as Aunt Maggie it's also
foreshadowing because he eventually
kills Nadine the same way he killed Dan
mag by throwing her out a window she
ends up landing on a statue of the
Virgin Mary causing the image to
resemble Michelangelo's sculpture pieta
which depicts Jesus dying in the arms of
Mary I feel like this may be connected
to Nadine returning as an angel but I
don't really know anything about the
Catholic lore there's also a shot while
Nadine is doing her Hail Mary is where
she Pats a smaller statue in the head
maybe a small clue that she'll be
landing on a statue's head after the
brainwashing is complete Lexi is tasked
with keeping an eye on Chucky and he
asks her a variety of annoying questions
one of which is do you have a cat this
is a callback to season one episode one
where Chucky's first victim is Jake's
cat we also see him take out a cat in
the 2019 remake episode 4 is a weird one
it's called Death on denial a play on
and Death on the Nile in 1978 mystery
film which is fitting because this
episode is all about a murder history
party there's a line that caught my
attention where Glenda mentions having
spoken to Tiffany Jennifer's accountant
Stan Stan was the name of Jennifer's
limo driver secret lover in seed he
appeared to have died at the end of that
movie but then again so did Jennifer
Tilly however when we meet Jennifer
Tilly she appears to be Tiffany's
accountant I'm not really sure what's
going on here or if we'll ever find out
before the guests arrive the three can
be seen eating Swedish meatballs for
dinner Tiffany specialty and Chucky's
supposed favorite food speaking of
favorite foods when the real Jennifer
Tilly does appear she's got one thing on
her mind roll it
I'm starving you promised me
got her into this mess in the first
place she only encountered Tiffany
Valentine because she snuck into a prop
room at the movie studio to secretly
snack on chocolate if you're like me you
probably had a lot of questions about
this party that remain unanswered
primarily why is Glenn and Glenda's
birthday being celebrated in November
when we already know that they were born
in March 2004. I swear they're just
trying to make the timeline difficult
for me at this point but who are these
seemingly random party gas what is their
significance and why does this Butler
look so familiar I have all of the
answers that Liv Morgan didn't
[Music]
the twins wanted a surprise party so
they invited some of their mother's
friends to the house without her knowing
to surprise them this already doesn't
make sense but it may have been a
strategy to help distract her making it
easier for Glenn and Glenda to sneak out
Nika so who are these people Auntie Gina
is introduced first she isn't anyone's
real Aunt I think she's more of an
honorary Aunt for the twins kind of like
how Aunt Maggie wasn't Andy's real Aunt
she's just a friend of his mother her
full name is Gina Gershon and she
co-starred with Jennifer Tilly in the
1996 Thriller bound where the two shared
a lesbian relationship which we find out
is real in the world of Chucky in fact
when Gina sneaks up on her in the
bedroom you can see the bound poster in
the background at that very moment
similarly Uncle pants is not Glenn and
Glenda's real Uncle he's Joe pantelliano
another actor friend who was also in
Bound where he plays Jennifer Tilly's
boyfriend Caesar apparently he too has
an ongoing relationship with her and we
literally see him get caught with his
pants down then there's sudden Strack I
guess Jennifer and Sutton are just
friends in real life the final guess is
Meg Tilly the real-life sister of
Jennifer Tilly when I first heard she
was going to be cast for season two I
assumed she was going to be playing
Tiffany's sister who was referenced in
seed and as far as we know is still
alive but I was wrong she's just playing
herself ironically Meg actually is Glenn
and Glenda's Aunt because the twins
biological mother is Jennifer Tilly the
butler is the only one who isn't playing
himself but if he still looks familiar
it may be because the actor Tony Napo
played Gus coleard in the saw franchise
as if that wasn't enough star power the
episode ends with a sit down between
Chucky and WWE star Liv Morgan and I
just gotta say what is the deal lately
with these WWE Stars being able to
manipulate entertainers for guest spots
seemingly at will between this the Alexa
Bliss song by bowling Pursuit and the
time dead meat did like a whole podcast
season of just WWE Stars I'd like to
know who runs their marketing team or
maybe you just have to be a WWE Fan to
get it but I guess if Justin Fields
randomly wanted to come on cz's world
yeah I'd probably do it there's one more
item I'd like to point out in this
episode but I do need to spoil the movie
Psycho to do it so spoiler alerts until
the end of this chapter after the butler
is found and everybody's discussing who
the killer could be the finger is
pointed at Glenn and Glenda to which
Glenn says we wouldn't hurt a fly those
who have seen my Seed of Chucky episode
may have picked up on this in that movie
Glenn and Glenda are a split personality
both trapped inside the body of this
doll switching back and forth in regards
to who's in control it's the same
concept as Norman and Norma Bates in
Psycho and as a result there are a ton
of psycho references in C so this line
is also a psycho reference at the end of
the movie we hear Norma's internal
monologue and in an attempt to look
innocent she says this probably watching
me let them see what kind of a person I
am I'm not even gonna sweat that fly and
they'll say
but she wouldn't even harm a fly and
this idea comes back a couple episodes
later as Jake Devin Lexi and Nadine are
still trying to determine if their
reprogrammed Chucky is really dangerous
or not he literally kills a fly
foreshadowing that he's not the harmless
doll that Jake thinks he is one more
maybe psycho reference When Tiffany
slices up mag Tilly the music sounds a
lot like the music in Psycho
[Music]
after Awakening from a bad dream Glenn
can be seen reading Great Expectations
this novel was written by British author
Charles Dickens a call back to Glenn's
childhood spent in the UK before ever
being reborn as a human that day when
Tiffany asked what happened to Nika and
Glenda I noticed Glenn's eye give a
little twitch tell me where Glenda took
Mika
this is something that happened in seed
Glenn's eye would twitch under stressful
circumstances that are just too much to
deal with Tiffany's outfit during the
scene contains these strange playing
cards probably referencing her career as
a professional poker player which I
talked about in season one anyway after
Glenn discovers the real Gentilly
trapped in doll form Tiffany burns down
the house which feels very unnecessary
back at the school the brainwashed Scout
Chucky fights and defeats buff Sharky
and in the aftermath father Bryce orders
sister Ruth to throw away the tattered
doll it's an important Chucky tradition
for someone to try to trash the
antagonistic toy this is the eighth time
someone has attempted it as we get
further into the season there are more
and more callbacks to the original movie
series for example Andy is now being
kept prisoner by Chucky in a cabin where
he's tortured it's revenge for when Andy
kept Chucky's head as his prisoner in
his cabin and tortured him cool detail
about the cabin if you bring up the
lights you can see many knives stored
overhead probably the knives of each of
the Chuckies that the colonel has killed
sister Ruth is the next to discover that
Chucky is alive and he tells her that
she should be blonde he told Tiffany the
same thing when they first met in the
Flash back during season 1 which
suggests that Chucky may have a thing
for sister Ruth as Kyle Nika and Glenda
are staying in a hotel on route to New
Jersey Kyle has a pack of cigarettes
labeled Kincaid as far as I know this
isn't a brand that you can still find so
it must be a reference to Jade Kincaid
from Bride of Chucky one of the few
surviving characters who has yet to make
an appearance in the TV series also Kyle
has a necklace that says mom on it which
is a strange thing for an orphan to have
a report comes on the TV breaking the
news that Jennifer Tilly is not wanted
for murder the photo that they use is
from the 2019 Saturn Awards the Saturns
were briefly mentioned by Jake and Devin
in season one if you're curious the
photo used in the second news report
where Tiffany freaks out about the
terrible picture they used of her was
taken at the premiere of Panic Room in
2002. it's weird that they would use
such an old photo but it's the perfect
opportunity for me to promote my things
you missed episode on Panic Room at Lord
incarnate father Bryce puts the School
on lockdown but Lexi and Nadine are able
to reach Jake and Devin's room anyways
by climbing out of their window and into
the boy's window they probably expected
us to forget that they showed the
outside of Lexi in Nadine's room and
unless they're both Spider-Man there's
no way the girls pulled this off the
creators of the show need to stop
underestimating me I didn't forget when
the twins birthday is and I didn't
forget what the exterior of the school
looks like either Andy helps them Ambush
and defeat the colonel but before he can
get the Scout Dr mixer shows up with a
gun and takes Chucky away I'm not quite
sure how they let her do this yeah she
has a gun but there are five of them if
she even tried to use the gun the rest
of them could quickly pounce on her then
she somehow beats up Andy she has the
chance to shoot him right here but she
doesn't for some reason episode 7 is
called go into the chapel I think it's
referring to a lyric from the Dixie cup
song Chapel of love this episode is all
about The Exorcism of scout Chucky to
make room for Chucky Prime to leave
Nika's body we later find out this is
kind of pointless because Dr mixture
already has a backup Chucky and her safe
I'll ignore that though because I have
something else that I would like to
complain about
[Music]
the biggest obstacle that the characters
have to overcome in every installment is
Chucky but there are also obstacles on a
character level in each movie in Child's
Play Andy is not taken seriously because
he's a kid in curse Nika wants to get
her family to see her as a person not
see her for her disability season 2 is
all about Jake and Devin wanting those
around them to accept their relationship
they are trapped into school and
religion that doesn't accept them
they're constantly trying to invalidate
that religion so I just find it weird
that they successfully perform an
exorcism at the end because doesn't that
kind of say that the religion really
does have power it's not super shocking
because Voodoo is a religion that gave
Chucky power in the very first movie but
it feels somewhat contradictory the deal
to perform the exorcism is struck when
Kyle shows up with a gun leveling the
playing field against Dr Mixter what'd
you do to your hair I wasn't having any
fun as a blonde because holding each
other at gunpoint is the perfect time to
strike up a casual conversation about
women's hair at this point everyone is
brought together to help perform the
exorcism other than Tiffany Jennifer and
one who are still on their way however
Jennifer would not make it after 18
years of being trapped inside this doll
she seizes her opportunity to make a run
for it and gets whacked by a truck this
is a franchise callback David from Bride
of Chucky suffers the exact same fate
he's hit by a truck while trying to
escape from Tiffany Valentine while
preparations are made to perform the
exorcism Chucky is tied up leaving him
to verbally torture everyone so Andy
locks Chucky away in a bookshelf this is
a reference to the way that Hannibal
lecture was tied up in Silence of the
Lambs and he even pulls out the same
line closer
[Music]
closer if you watched my season one
episode you learned about how Don
Mancini's time on the Hannibal TV show
it may have been the reason that Chucky
made the move to syndicated programming
in the first place but the episode is
primarily more of a takeoff on another
classic horror film your mother sucks
we've all seen that movie too the movie
he's referring to is the Exorcist where
the little girl Regan is possessed by
the demon Pazuzu to say the same line
her possession causes her to switch from
the innocent girl to the evil demon
hurling psychological attacks at those
tending to her we see Scout Chucky do
the same thing as he toggles between
good Chucky and evil Chucky Chucky also
takes after Reagan by projectile
vomiting a green substance and
levitating up in the air just like in
The Exorcist the ending of The Exorcist
involves The Possession being passed to
the priest shortly before his death and
Chucky follows suit with the implosion
of Father Bryce now all they have to do
is transfer Chucky Prime's soul out of
Nika's body into the doll however all
the guns have been locked up at this
point I don't understand why they don't
just tie up Dr mixer first then exercise
Chucky from Nico's body but they don't
think of that this show is so
frustrating this mistake allows sister
Ruth to show up and rescue the newly
transferred Chucky but she stopped by
Glenda using a knife Hidden Away by
Charles Lee Ray as a kid I need you to
go get my old Bowie knife I stashed it
in a loose Stone behind the church organ
back in no no the season finale is
called Chucky actually because it takes
place on Christmas like the 2003
Christmas movie Love Actually we see Dr
Mixter now possessed by Chucky Prime go
into the safe at her office to retrieve
the spare Good Guy doll the safe
passcode is 110988 or 110988 the release
date of the original Child's Play
Another Easter egg to the original is
the maker of the save Caputo Safe
Company this isn't a real brand so it
must be another reference to Charles's
old accomplice Eddie caputa the intro to
this episode shows many of the weapons
that Chucky has used over the years
including the snake adorned knife scene
in the original and in curse the hammer
used to knock Aunt Maggie out the window
in the original the red chain saw that
he would later use in this episode the
generic kitchen knife which has been
used many times and to the yardstick
that he beat Miss kettlewell with in
Child's Play 2. Lexi asked her mom if
her orphaned friends can stay for the
holidays while Mrs cross is live
streaming she claims that she was
streaming to 100 000 followers which is
total BS if I go on Twitch or YouTube
right now the top channels are getting
maybe a quarter of that I guarantee no
one is tuning in to watch a small all
town mayor decorate her Christmas tree
on Facebook no less and later she claims
this my followers really seem to love my
nativity scene got over 30 000 likes no
there are only 45 000 people in
Hackensack come on and when she's
streaming that nativity scene the
on-screen phone POV doesn't match up
with how she's moving around the phone
how do you screw that up inside Caroline
and Bell who is secretly Chucky in
Disguise are watching the news about
what happened at the Lord incarnate
school this calls back to child Supply 1
where Andy and Chucky watch the news for
updates on Eddie Caputo I already talked
about the defibrillator used to take out
the hospital security guy being another
potential Child's Play reference like
the shock device in one why would they
even have a tool powerful enough to
light someone on fire in the hospital
and are we just supposed to assume that
there are no smoke detectors in this
Hospital make it make sense the
season-long revisit to Seed of Chucky
comes full circle when Glenn and Glenda
transfer back into the doll body from
that movie taking on to the new name
Gigi as another tribute to seed Gigi has
a jacket patch that resembles one of the
Seed of Chucky posters one of the the
other patches is Tiffany's original
tattoo but the business between Chucky
and the trio of Jake Devin and Lexi is
not finished yet he breaks into the
house through the chimney as he had in
Child's Play and in season one also this
season began with him escaping up a
chimney and now he's coming down one
Tiffany Valentine can also be found
breaking into the house looking for the
Bell doll to transfer her own soul into
but she's caught by Mrs cross oh my God
this is so random and I'm sorry to
bartend on your house on Christmas Eve
no worries this is it this is the script
we're going with
okay
Chucky season 2 ends with one final
similarity to C both stories involve
Chucky breaking into somewhere he's not
supposed to be trying to get revenge on
Tiffany and getting a surprise attack
from a kid only this time there's
another Twist on top of that I mean it's
not a new twist oh my God Dr Foley was
evil the whole time Dr mixer was evil
the whole time Caroline was evil the
whole time who could have seen this
coming I realized that I was kind of
negative during this episode I usually
try to give my analysis with more of a
neutral tone but it's just hard when the
characters don't make smart choices like
why did Lexie leave the chainsaw
downstairs when she knew that Tiffany
was still upstairs it's just frustrating
but I do have hope at the beginning of
this video I discussed how season one
was an homage to Child's Play 2 and
disappointingly season 2 falls back into
the old ways of Seed of Chucky but what
if that's not necessarily the intention
what if season one is actually a tribute
to the entire Child's Play Arc Child's
Play Child's Play 2 and Child's Play 3.
that would mean that season 2 is
actually a tribute to the bride's Cedar
Chucky has been renewed for season three
so maybe just maybe season three will be
focused on the cursed cult art bringing
back the horror the suspense and the
psychological manipulation of the 2010.
so let me know what your thoughts are in
the comments I'll be here to cover
season three once it's available and
I'll be updating my Chucky character
timelines as well so make sure you
subscribe to cz's world for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell for all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]
thank you